covered 90 public engagement board i
will start by wishing you all happy new
year um
thank you for your attendance this
morning i have received apologies this
morning just from council acton and
there are no further apologies are there
any decorations of interest in today's
agenda items at all
don't cindy thank you
can we take the minutes of the last
meeting as read an accurate record which
is held on the 15th of december 2021
thank you very much
uh a lot has happened in the last three
weeks and i'm sure that our director of
public health and her team have been
pulling their hair out over a lot of
things
so with no further ado i will pass over
to helen collins to give us the latest
update on the current covered 19
situation in trafford helen welcome
thank you
thank you chair and uh yeah a blatant
happy new year to everyone on the call
as well
so um
we're in quite a different place than we
were when we
last met as the purp in december
um so our rates are now significantly
higher as are the national rates so
where we currently are up to friday the
7th of january for trafford our rates
are now at 1
960 per 100 000
so if we put that in terms of numbers of
residents for the seven days before the
7th of january
4
658 of our residents tested positive for
covid
um
and that if we compare that to the seven
days previous actually
um our rates have dropped a very small
amount so this is the bit of the green
shoots that we're clinging on to at the
moment in public health
so our rates are starting to look like
they're stabilizing and are very very
slowly very small
uh marginal amounts starting to drop
which is which is a positive i think for
us in trafford
um but we'd still have to be mindful
that there might be a number of reasons
behind that
which might include um
people's access or perception of access
to testing um which may have reduced
numbers of people coming forward however
ben is on the call and can talk us
through that later on but still it's
good news i think at this point
we had historically been um number one
in greater manchester for a long time in
terms of our rates we're now currently
number nine with wigan holding the top
spot at the moment but if we think back
to before christmas wigan was
consistently the lowest so we can really
see the impact that the omicron wave has
had across the whole of greater
manchester and nationally as well
in terms of our
age groups and rates our age uh our
rates
are the highest in the zero to 44s but
we're starting to see an increase now in
over 45s
um and our rates in our over 60s group
is at uh one
two hundred and sixty seven per hundred
thousand
um and again that's looking to have
stabilized but that's a significant
increase in where we were in december
that that if we split that figure as
well um
the older
population over 74's has got a slightly
higher rate as well but we are seeing
that playing out in our care homes at
the moment which i'll talk you through
in a moment
um the other thing to be mindful of in
age groups at the moment is obviously
schools have had a break they did
our schools across trafford were
brilliant and did the return to school
testing last week and so at the moment
this week and next week we're just
waiting to see what happens we're
thinking that if if it takes off in our
schools it will be this next week
there's some really interesting
discussion about
what it is that we might see so we may
see
real significant disruption to our
schools and to our young people through
infection but there's also um
a kind of a thought as well around that
actually a lot of our young people will
have have got acquired immunity from
recent infection and vaccinations so we
may not see the numbers
that that we are expecting so at the
moment it's very much a watch and wait
but our outbreak team and our education
team are ready
and poised to support schools in
whichever way they can
so in terms of where we sit within um
greater manchester as i said we are near
the bottom now and our positivity is at
36. so that's the proportion of people
who go for a pcr test and end up
positive
end up returning a positive result which
is still really really high but not the
highest in greater manchester in terms
of our geographies our wards with the
highest rates are particularly around
the west of the borough so david hume
east timperley flixton david hume west
rr4 top four but what we are still
concerned about very much so is our
communities where we know that covert
would have a higher impact in terms of
health consequence and social
consequence so uh wards such as
stretford but close eight martins which
is partington area and gorse hill for
example have equally as high rates they
are
in and around the 2000 mark
and the concern for us as a public
health team in addition to the kind of
health consequences are that we know in
those areas and vaccination uptake is
lower so our community engagement team
are working very much with those
communities at the moment
in terms of um
age groups i talked through you through
the age group issue um
but obviously we're still waiting to see
whether the back to school excuse the
age group prevalence but the other thing
that we have seen and it's the the
concerning um aspect of omicron and the
pandemic uh which you won't have failed
to notice through the media is the
impact that we've got on our acute trust
at the moment which is significant
so um
we have the data's updated every
thursday for us so up to sunday the 2nd
of january
there were 528 admissions covered
related admissions to all hospitals
across greater manchester from across
greater manchester so this isn't
trafford specific
for the same time period that we would
compare it to there were 284 so that the
number of people admitted to hospital
with covid has doubled
and that is in addition to what we would
usually see at this time of year where
we would see our more vulnerable or
people with long-term health conditions
potentially being admitted due to a
number of other different reasons so
that is adding significantly to the
pressures
and our our teams this week have been
working with diane eaton and the adult
social care team to support and enable
safe discharge from hospitals so that
you know more so just to support that
kind of um element of pressure and the
hospitals at the moment are in
significant escalation
but but the system the gm system is
working really well to address those
issues
what i would say though is that the
mechanical ventilation beds are staying
reasonably stable as well we're not
seeing as many people who are admitted
to hospital with covert being as
severely ill as they previously were
which we would um
kind of attribute to the vaccine i think
at this point
but also potentially to the variant as
well because what we have seen is that
the omicron variant is less severe which
will hopefully mean that this peak will
be a lot shorter however the delta
variant is still circulating which is
more severe so um you know we still need
to be very mindful of the impact of
delta but at the moment we're we're
seeing about 90 of infections being
omicron
so the mechanical ventilation beds are
staying reasonably stable as are our
reported death rates so um the numbers
of people from trafford who die as a
result of covid is still remaining
really low and stable which is really
reassuring but what we do need to be
mindful of is obviously the tail so
although we've seen the peak in numbers
often the hospitalizations and
the deaths will follow three to four
weeks after so our analysts are watching
this data really really carefully
working with colleagues at greater
manchester to understand who is going
into hospital how long they're staying
in hospital their vaccination status and
their location of discharge afterwards
as well to understand a bit more of the
demographics
so that's where we are in terms of the
ep
in terms of the updates
um
obviously the booster program has been
going from strength to strength
and
marks on the call who can update us on
that and jilla as well the other issues
around the vaccination is obviously the
12 to 15 program has started again and
we're working really well with our mft
colleagues um but the issues for both
the programmes are very much around the
inequalities and particularly in the
north but jilla can update us on that
in terms of testing there's obviously
been a significant change around lfd
testing so from yesterday
if you tested positive on an lfd test at
home
um and you had no symptoms then you do
not have to have a confirmatory pcr the
the most important bit of that whole
sentence is have no symptoms um our
concern is um we know anecdotally that
people say oh i feel a little bit unwell
so i've done an lfd test it's really
important that people are asymptomatic
when they do that and then subsequently
don't have the pcr test they have to
have no symptoms
and then our concern really is just
about how that may impact on numbers and
figures coming through again we're
working with our analysts to understand
what that will look like in terms of
reporting but then we'll mark our
testing needs on the call so he can
update us further when we come through
testing
in terms of outbreaks um the outbreak
hub has been busy right across the
christmas new year period
um and um
and and continues to be busy this week
so we know that we've got a number of
schools i think as of yesterday we had
two high schools and seven primaries in
my outbreak but as you know that changes
from day to day and our care homes
majority of our care homes have outbreak
situations but our ipc our infection
prevention and control team and outbreak
hub are working really closely alongside
our care homes and care settings to
support them at the moment
again the key issue there is very much
around staffing so um staffing absence
either through sickness or to the need
to
care for children who may be positive as
well has had a huge impact
um i think we had 82 school staff
members out on on monday and obviously
that fluctuates day to day so we are
away from the covid side of the um
keeping schools running our education
team led by count samples is really
engaging with the schools to support
them at this point in time
businesses as well traffic prides itself
on its um
you know
businesses and particularly um settings
such as the trafford center we are aware
that they've been incredibly busy over
christmas our regulatory team and
outbreak team are working with all the
all the stores and the traffic center
team to support them at the moment in
terms of ensuring that that shops and
settings are doing all they can to be
covered secure
and then finally our community
engagement team um led by gillette and
catherine o'connor are doing some
excellent work looking at the
inequalities that are emerging from the
vaccination program particularly
focusing on the north so i'll leave that
for jilla and catherine to um to share
that really good work
so that's really how our team has
responded over the last four or five
weeks um it has been incredibly busy um
but but i feel like we have everything
in hand as is at the moment but i would
say um in terms of the messages from our
team vaccinate vaccinate vaccinate i
think mark would agree booster if you've
not had your booster please go and have
your booster um and if you've not had
your first or second
just please go and book into your first
and second you know it's really really
important and the evidence is really
strong in terms of protection not just
for you but for your um families friends
and communities
um to keep following the covered
measures so you know to keep that two mr
meter distance wear your face coverings
hand hygiene and be very symptom aware
as well and ultimately if you do have
any symptoms of um
covid to isolate and to get a pcr test
if you are symptomatic so i think they
would be our key messages from public
health at the moment but my colleagues
can fill you in with the details so
thank you very much
thank you helen for that very very
thorough update can i just remind uh
people if you're not speaking can you
please ensure that you're on mute uh
thank you there's some background coming
through there uh i'm gonna open it to
questions are there any questions please
uh for uh helen
i don't see any hands raised so i don't
see one waving at me so how did that
clearly oh yes uh counselor new grosh
sorry thank you for the briefing it's
more of a clarification um can i just
check that was 36 percent was that 36
percent um positivity you said um
on the rates
uh because if so that's very very high
um
it is that's that's correct cancer
so we are at 36 but we're not the
highest in greater manchester so that's
one thing to take away from the positive
to it but yeah the positivity rate is
the rates at the moment and the figures
at the moment are so
so far away from where we were this time
last year but you know it's all
comparative and relative isn't it to
other areas as well
okay and the other thing that is a
comparative that you i wanted to raise
the second of jan admissions figures
which you gave 528
is that you giving the previous week or
the previous year the same time last
year was 284 was it
done so it's a seven day let me just
check let me just check the wording for
you it's 14 days previous to the 2nd of
january
from that 14 day period 528 people were
admitted to hospital with covid in
greater manchester and then um it would
be the the 14 weeks at the 40 weeks 14
days previous to that was 284 okay so
you can see how the rates have doubled
here
yeah and yeah that's where we are and
we're we are expecting
the the upward curve so we are
stabilizing on infection um infections
hopefully but the upward curve that we
saw in the previous week so it's not yet
through in the hospitalizations is it
that's going to exist so that's yeah so
that's what we're we're watching very
carefully for at the moment is that
hospital emissions and
mortality impact as well which we should
start to see really this week and next
week i would say
thank you very much for clearing that up
thank you counseling you've watched
class accordingly
thanks chair um it's the question i put
in message i i couldn't ask at the time
by a microphone there was too much noise
in the room here
um from another meeting um
yes so i i'm after information about how
many
um
teachers and teacher
and education staff are absent because
of contact
rather than infection
and there's a reason for me asking for
that and trying to work out um
how much it affects other schools
so um
at the moment you only have to isolate
if you're a contact if you aren't
vaccinated you don't have the two
vaccinations so we don't hold that as an
outbreak
team
unless kirsty can correct me on that so
we would know how many staff members are
not in school because they are cases
but we can take that away and explore it
for you um if that would be helpful
council accordingly well if i could just
take that a little bit further because
that's my po
that's my understanding it's only the
unvaccinated that are having
and what i'm
what i'm picking up on is attention
over that issue because um
it can happen again and again
and i don't i doubt if it's restricted
to education settings although it's
particularly important to that so the
pressure there is a tension between
those that um
are continually absent
because they've come into contact
and
it's something that we may need to
understand as that goes on because
there's tension from other staff who
have having to cover
from vaccinated staff who are having to
cover
from the school itself who are having to
pay for
supply
teachers and other equivalents
and so that this is a new sort of um
schism if you like
and i i do sense that whether it be the
teaching facility or whether it be a
post office or whatever there's
increasing pressure on those that are
unvaccinated
now
um
that that may escalate over the next few
months so it becomes much more severe
and i certainly know about one school
that's thinking of uh or one trust
that's thinking about not paying sick
leave for that now
that filters into the vaccination
strategy quite a lot because we need to
be there
for people that are
i wouldn't say forced but on on second
thoughts do decide that vaccination is
there so we need to make sure we can
pick up these people quite quickly
because
i'm only reporting this because i know
one school i'm associated with it's
becoming a growing concern
for care homes vaccination is now under
mandated as will be for the nhs from the
1st of
april i haven't heard of any discussions
around the education sector at the
moment but there are you will haven't
seen in the media this week that number
of
high-profile companies have also changed
their policy around vaccination and sick
pay i don't think we can comment on that
as a public health
organization but um and it would be very
much a national debate or for
organizations to to change their health
and hr policy accordingly
um i think that's all i can say really
thank you
uh thanks council courtney i think it's
interesting that i could pick up in the
media this week ikea are certainly uh
not going to pay sick pay um to
unvaccinated stuff they'll be on
saturday sick pay and they've already
announced that but i think it's a point
well made by you um but helen's quite
right public health can't really comment
on it at this stage thank you are there
any further questions at all oh yes i've
got
mark mark jarvis
god i can't hear you mark are you mute
mine was saying i wasn't but uh maybe
you can hear me now um so along with the
booster campaign we're offering what's
called an evergreen
um offer so anybody who hasn't been
vaccinated
or you know is late for a second dose
they can turn up or book appointments at
the clinics that are either bookable and
there's a significant number of walk-ins
available now um and there is plenty of
capacity across trafford to be able to
cope with the boosters and anybody else
who decides at any point in time that uh
that they would
like to change their mind and avail
themselves of that opportunity so we're
aware of it um and you know we have
good capacity to ensure that we can
supply that if it is required
thank you mark um
i don't see any further questions thank
you helen uh so can we move on then to
mass testing and ben welcome ben
thanks very much chair morning everyone
can i just check everyone can hear me i
know there's some sound issues today
i've seen a thumbs up fantastic so i
know it's been a while since we've met
so i've just pulled together a
very brief powerpoint presentation
um
just to kind of talk through some of the
changes that have happened
and uh
it's not deciding to share which is
there we go perfect so um first things
first i'll talk through we've had two
changes in terms of guidance um over the
past um three or four weeks um so first
of all this is around ending
self-isolation early um so it's now
possible to end self-isolation after
seven days um and this is following um
two negative lots watcher flow tests
taking 24 hours apart so you can start
this by testing on day six and then day
seven and can continue once each day
until you have two negatives and you
also crucially um need to not have a
high temperature
so you shouldn't take any more electric
flow tests after the 10th day of your
isolation period and you may stop self
isolating after that day so that's part
one and then part two obviously that
came in yesterday's helen touched on
before is that people who receive a
positive electric flow test no longer
need to go and get a confirmatory pcr
test however however however crucially
if you have symptoms you should still
absolutely go and get that pcr test um
if you um
need to go and get the self-isolation
payment you will also be required to go
get that confirmatory pcr test as well
so the other bit that helen touched on a
lot in terms of testing is with regards
to
um difficulties getting hold of tests so
if we start off unlock your flow test we
know it's been a challenge especially
over them online and through pharmacies
so in terms of the work that we've been
doing here at trafford our testing team
has taken a massive amount of work to
ensure that when it comes to residents
they've been able to collect lots of
flow tests from our libraries a that's
stratford um sale um and then the key
staff group so gps schools social care
settings such as care homes and home
care they've been able to go and get
tests either through direct delivery or
by coming to travel town hall to pick up
the test from there and that's been
really really successful so far and for
staff groups we've been able to continue
to provide those when it comes to
libraries by and large maybe one day
here or there but by large we've been
able to keep them fully stocked um most
of the time
so in total in the last four weeks
through our deliveries libraries or
collection we've handed out over 72 000
tests now to give you an idea of how
many that is um we did that many in the
previous 21 weeks so in that four week
period you've really done so much in
terms of giving out those those tests
and making sure that where possible
residents and staff have been able to
access those tests
so our key advice and our key messaging
for this at the moment is
first of all check online
and if there's any immediately available
check back in later um the national team
has put much more capacity into the
ordering system so it should now be much
easier to go and order kits direct to
your front door second of all local
pharmacies have been told that more
stock is available so again maybe with
having a quick phone call first with
them just to make sure but pharmacies
should start seeing more tests turn up
there and then finally you know we've
got tests out strategies and selling
nutrition library again
maybe worth a quick phone call first
just to make sure but by and large we
have been able to to keep those those
lively stocked up and then the final
quick bit is on pcr tests again i know
there has been some delay when it comes
to getting results that's been down to
lab capacity rather than lack of tests
themselves however we have seen an
improvement picture over the past few
weeks or so and the department health
and social care have reported a
significant drop in demand for pcr
testing since the announcement um
obviously came in yesterday around not
needing that confirmatory pcr test so
your weight for a pcr test should also
start to drop again which is really
positive so again just drawing those key
messages continues in a lot of your flow
tests especially before you go out and
see um anyone and you know anytime you
put in a situation that could be a
little bit risky or you'll see multiple
people and then finally as helen said be
symptom aware and if you have any of
those symptoms go and get yourself a pcr
test
and
that's everything for me um on testing
chair if there's any questions
uh thanks ben can i just ask is all that
information now fully available on the
uh on the trafford council website
yes so on the traffic council website we
link in um to the testing page that we
have on the service directory so in
order to get hold of tests yes people
are assigned posted there through those
different routes
because i wasn't aware that the
libraries were giving them out so that's
new information to me to be perfectly
honest but i think i think uh our
residents be very pleased to know that
that's the case
we set it up chair um right at the start
of this before the actual pharmacy offer
came in and then it was probably about
three weeks later the family offers made
available and at that point honestly we
did such a slow amount of tests through
those libraries um that um people you
know we made them aware of it but most
people just went to the closest pharmacy
they had it's only been as we've seen
that struggle to get um stock through
those pharmacies the libraries have seen
that massive massive increase in demand
going forward
thank you i've got a question from
is it mark mark jarvis first
thank you um actually it's i'd like to
record my thanks on behalf of healthcare
um healthcare with the
escalation of the booster program having
to set up extra vaccination clinics
struggle to get enough lateral flows um
at that period of time to allow the
staff to be able to work and we're
supported by public health and the
council to be able to function so
actually it's not really a question it's
just uh i'd like to record my thanks for
the sport that helped us to be able to
perform our role
thank you mark it's team works the best
way forward isn't it around this
absolutely excellent uh judith
councillor lloyd
i'd just like to make a comment um
following ben's um uh talk because
um i ordered uh the lateral flow test um
online
and um went to the pharmacy to go and
pick them up to tell me they didn't have
any but they sent me to stretford
library who were dealing out loads
that morning so it has been a success um
using the libraries and i'm very
grateful because we did need those
lateral flow tests thanks
that's really nice to hear thank you
very much
thank you julia are there any further
questions at all for ben uh akilah i can
all account so canola
hi ben just um a point to clarify um
regarding these changes regarding
lateral flows and not doing a pcr unless
you're symptomatic is that the same for
care staff as well working in care homes
because i'm just thinking of the numbers
of staff that would potentially be off
if they've been asymptomatic had a piece
had a lateral flow
and because we've had our work in health
and social care we've had lots of
incidences where people have done
lateral flow that come up positive and
then done a pcr and it's been negative
so does that have been any changes
regarding um care staff
knows and key figures
so no matter what my understanding and
again um helen will will jump in here if
if that's not the case that they're
still going to be required to do um the
regular racing time to test in both
electrical flow and pcr
um in terms of those i i i think that
the delays in terms of getting those
those tests back has been a key issue
but again hopefully now that those
changes have come in place that that
care staff will start to see those those
pcr tests come back um in a much quicker
way which is obviously positive in
general i know we have had some
instances where a lack of flow test is
positive and the pci is negative by and
large i know overall it does happen very
very rarely so i know there are some
instances and especially at the moment
where we've seen such high rates of
positivity as hell spoke about before um
that that should that could should
happen even less than it is at the
moment
thanks thank you and uh mark do you want
to come back in please
yeah thank you um this was just
clarified for healthcare staff the
guidance hasn't changed tequila so if
anybody has a positive lateral flow in
their routine
testing and their healthcare staff they
are obliged to still have a pcr
so so i know that it hasn't changed in
health
thank you for that clarification i don't
see any further questions so thank you
ben
um let's move on then to contact tracing
outbreak management uh welcome kirsty
hi good morning thank you
um so this week i think we've got the
majority of our schools that are now
back in school um in fact all schools
have a cross traffic and now back
obviously that's been a staggered return
across the primaries in the high schools
so since returning after the christmas
break we are seeing
an increase in cases across education
and early years settings again
and it's difficult to get an accurate
picture because some schools report
cases from over the holidays
and some
report just since they returned so
until we're about two weeks in after
schools have returned
and understanding what school
transmission looks like and because it's
a mixture of community transmission over
the holidays and some since they've
returned
we are
obviously continue to work really
closely with our primary secondaries and
early year settings
and and
even though we're in the early days we
are seeing a number of
um small light breaks across our
primaries and our secondaries
and i think with every other sector
we're seeing a high positive
amount of cases amongst staff in
education
and which will obviously
impact
on staffing levels across early years
and the schools and we just continue to
keep monitoring that and providing the
appropriate advice and support to
schools
again um just because of the
high rates across trafford there's been
a significant increase in positive cases
um across our workplace sector and our
businesses
and so the team we're working closely
with environmental health and some
additional support that we've got
um from from another team where we've
got a prioritization framework of when
we will make contact with a business and
so where we're seeing businesses with a
high number of cases or it's a critical
infrastructure
or there's other
significant factors that means that we
need to make contact with that business
we are contacting them and advising them
and making sure that relevant staff are
isolated and that they're doing that
contact racing within businesses
that's the biggest increase that we've
seen for a while across our work
workforce sector and again just
reassurances that we are working with
those businesses
and
helen and ben have obviously already
mentioned the changes to pcr testing and
i just wanted to emphasize that if
somebody intends or they're eligible for
claiming the self-isolation support
payment so that's the 500 payment they
must follow up
an lfd test with a pcr test and that
needs to happen as soon as possible and
it needs to be within their isolation
period and you know i
i don't want our residents to come back
to us 10 days later um and not
understand that rule that they needed
the pcr test and miss out on that
support payment so that is really really
key
and i just wanted to emphasize that
again even though it's been said a
number of times
and
our local contact tracing so obviously
we've always had a local contact racing
model in place and that's cases that we
follow up within trafford for contact
racing that haven't been reached by the
national team
and over the um period of december and
particularly these last couple of weeks
the local contact racing volumes have
just increased massively since the
beginning of december
so just to put that into perspective um
during the week ending of the 29th of
december
just under 20 000 cases were escalated
to local authorities across gm from the
national team for follow-up and
comparing that to the first week of
december that was just two just under 3
000
so we've seen over a 700 increase across
greater manchester for local contact
racing cases so obviously the impact on
the team
is that
um our ability to reach people for
contact tracing has fallen in trafford
and that's also fallen across greater
manchester and we do have routes to to
escalate though de-escalate those back
to the national team
and so what i would encourage is that
our residents
they have an eight-hour digital journey
where they can complete contact tracing
online so i would encourage them to do
that
and that has also recently been
introduced for under 18s so previously
on drake teens could not complete the
digital journey but they can now so i
would encourage residents to do that
and and then finally just
with the lfd testing so the asymptomatic
lfd testing
um we encourage residents to register
the lfd test result and if they register
their lfd test result they will get
what's known as a c tas id so that is an
account id um to say that that that test
result was was positive when they do
register it so that would also be really
helpful because then that links them
into the national system
and that's all the updates from me thank
you
thanks sir
i know you re-emphasize there about the
the the need for a pcr following a left
if you require
the assistance money is that
is that emphasized on our on our website
as well that information is on on the
council website
yeah it is there and uh that's fine that
that's brilliant uh any questions at all
got no hands raised at all it's very
thorough update thank you kirsty
no no question so let's move on then to
um
mass vaccination i'll bring in mark
jarvis
thank you mark
thank you i'll i'll start with the
figures and then give you a bit of an
explanation so
um
as of the 4th of january which is the
last point we have complete data
we had delivered 163
600 first doses
100 which is 83 of the eligible
population
we delivered 157
000 second doses
which is 80 of the eligible population
and then that's the same populations
and we had delivered 82
or 20 126 000
booster vaccinations
the number of people eligible for the
booster vaccinations is less
because the 12 to 15 year olds are
receiving only two doses not three
and
some people um
due to the time period between the
second and booster dose are not yet
eligible
um
but yeah we had a massive so the the
narrative is we're trying to offer
vaccinations to everybody as much as was
mentioned previously you know during the
massive campaign in the second half of
december following
the government's push
we were delivering over 4000
vaccinations a day at stages between our
providers and i need to say thank you to
both our pharmacy providers
who actually deliver more than 50 of the
vaccinations as well as the gp network
sites
who are delivering the vaccinations
locally
as a consequence of that we are
performing well compared to others with
the best performing um locality within
greater manchester
um
and we are now adjusting
our capacity to to match what's needed
and the campaigns now are to address the
people who are not vaccinated um the
people who are reluctant for whatever
reason um
and also to remind those people who
possibly missed their booster
vaccination because they had covered so
that was a significant issue in the
second half of december that that they
are eligible for that booster dose 20
days 28 days after their infection
and for the best protection
they should still have a booster
vaccination as well as having had covid
contrary to the publicity that novak
djokovic is trying to give us at the
moment
um
so so
they're the headline figures we have as
i said earlier we've got the capacity
um across the trafford system in local
centers to be able to continue to
deliver
the
numbers required to uh
to you know
pick up those people when they come in
and we will continue to do the work on
inequalities trying to improve that
spread of vaccination across the area
as i'm sure is going to be explained
shortly
and i'm happy to answer any questions
and i know that's a a data-heavy
report but
that's where we're up to
thank you mark can i just um echo uh the
thanks you gave to the uh all those
involved in both the booster campaign
the vaccination program particularly the
pharmacies uh all the walk-in centres
and all the volunteers as well
and i think if i recall
did you not say the last meeting we had
167 000 boosters
by the end of december
yeah that they if i um the figures get
confusing but yes we
of the 167 000 that was our challenge we
delivered over 60
within before the 31st of december and
that got our total
numbers of over 80 of the eligible
population for that boost to do so so
yeah everybody stepped up and did
brilliantly that is that is a fantastic
result thank you are there any questions
at all
for mark from anybody
mark i don't see any can i thank you and
and and pass on our thanks again to to
everyone that's involved uh in in the
continuing work around booster and the
vaccination program thank you very much
thank you um so moving on we're on to
community engagement now i've got jilla
burgess allen and catherine o'connor who
wants to go first
catherine do you want to go first
welcome thank you
and can you see and hear me
great
so in terms of the engagement update
morning goal i'm just scrolling up in my
file
so as helen mentioned we've had a
particular focus on inequalities
particularly around vaccination recently
there was a big pre-christmas and
ongoing push in the north into that
inequality's work
and the team has been supporting the
booster and general covert vaccination
program
we've been sharing messaging promoting
vaccination local clinic times and
information about the gm booking
helplines that's the helpline that
people can contact if they need help
with booking in or finding local
appointments
and as well as continuing to share
information on self-isolation and code
safe behavior
and so some of the channels that we've
made that big push through have included
social media working with our cons team
and with partners
uh we've got the clinic list hosted on
the council website
and we've been linking in again with the
cons team on targeted digital ads so
that's um ads on websites that people
use in the borough to drive them towards
vaccination
we've also been linking with comms on
advance so that's mobile digital
advertising and the drives around and
can promote clinics when they're on and
so we've made use of those over late
december in areas with either
inequalities or lower vaccination uptake
and we've also been linking in with the
nhs street team so they made a visit to
the borough on the 24th of december
again promoting vaccination
and letting people know where the
clinics were and the benefits of
vaccination
and alongside that we've distributed
posters in key areas that's included
clinic time information as well so
that's been sites such as the community
clubs community buildings and shops
and we continue to make use of the
network of community champions that's
been distributing information to them
again sort of covered figures
vaccination key messages as well as
hearing from them their insights of what
they're hearing in the community and
building that into our programmes of
work
we've still got good links with faith
communities particularly what they're
the mosques in the north but also other
faith groups throughout the borough
as well as other community
groups and vcsc so community clubs
collective and that wider sector
and we've been producing a targeted
weekly mail out to that list of groups
and again that's included things around
vaccination and covert updates the key
messages
and then we've also been in contact with
our elected members in areas of lower
uptake or whether inequalities in order
to
have their assistance in pushing that
message which we'll be continuing to do
um so alongside the information i've
already mentioned we've also been
supplying updated nhs vaccine faqs
a vaccine promotion video that the ccg
have made with north primary care
network and a graphic for the egm
booking helpline that partners can share
to make people aware of that resource
and so in addition to that we've
been coordinating winter well-being
packs so our team had um created a small
number of those around 250 that we've
been getting out with our partners um in
advance of christmas
and then that offers now been extended
by adult social care and so that goal is
to help people stay safe and well at
home over winter during the very cold
weather and at a time when the health
system is very stretched
and so for that extension push um around
1 650 packs were distributed across the
borough with the help of volunteers and
so again i just want to say a big thanks
to everyone who helped enable that so
that was our community volunteers in
particular soul mothers
staff volunteers some of our executive
members that's including council
accordingly in council harding and
partners like amy and trafford leisure
and other partners in trafford
and those packs included practical items
to keep safe over winter but they also
included covered safe information and
vaccination information
we're linking in with some of our
community settings to
make best use of the digital screens
that are available throughout trafford
and so we've been supplying messaging
for digital signage at various locations
such as traffic housing trust buildings
and blue sky centres
and various community partners across
the borough
and so that messaging is again around
code 19 safety and also general health
messaging for winter around keeping warm
mental health staying active
and then that also includes key contact
information for services such as the
hubs if people do require any additional
support
um in terms of upcoming work and so a
big area of focus for us over the next
few weeks is the 15 vaccination program
which is both second doses and first
doses where people were missed first
time around
due to factors like absence or having
had covered recently when the
vaccination team visited
so we're ensuring that that's an
equitable approach and we'll be picking
up um with schools in areas where we
know people experience inequalities or
where there's lower uptake that first
time around
and that will be taking a whole family
approach and linking in schools directly
and with children's services
around how we can best support that
we're also currently developing some
resources around the make every contact
count approach and we're going to be
refreshing resources to send to key
frontline services which will mean that
when people in the community frontliners
are having conversations with our
residents they can also be discussing
covered vaccination and how to keep safe
in general
we're pulling together a new resource
pack um using some of those faqs and
particularly focusing on some of the
anti-vaxx talking points so that people
can feel that they're supported to have
conversations where there's anti-vaxx
sentiment
and then we're continuing to pull in and
all the insight from our vaccine
hesitancy survey into our work to help
shape that future activity
and so i think that's it for me unless
anyone has any questions
[Music]
thank you catherine gillard do you want
to come in and add anything at all
please
thank you chair well i think mark and
catherine have given a fairly
comprehensive update i think all i would
add from an equity point of view is in
addition we are looking to step up uh
some pop-up clinics um in areas where we
know uptake is lowest and targeting
those age groups where uptake has been
lower so for example engaging in some of
our retail spaces our college partners
etc and also doing some quite focused
work with certain cohorts of people that
are more vulnerable such as care leavers
and the homeless
so i think it's a very multi-pronged
approach that we're taking to try and
reduce those inequalities that we're
seeing
thank you well thank you jill uh any
questions at all
uh councillor new grosh
i well thank you for the presentation i
just wanted to add that those care packs
were i mean the targeting was a little
hit and miss but were so very useful for
making contacts with some of the more
vulnerable in our community
and i personally had
well half a dozen requests for onward
care from that and and i would like to
see those perhaps more structured next
year a repeat of that that was extremely
useful thank you
thank you council new grosh any further
questions at all
i don't see it thank you catherine thank
you jiller
um
we don't have any uh uh any other
business on the agenda today uh the date
of our next meeting will be the 26th of
january 2022 at the same time
let's just keep oh can't you want to
come in
just before you finish i just want to
ask you a cheeky question
um did your leader
follow in the footsteps of our prime
minister
in organizing a christmas due
in the town hall for your senior
councils and senior officers it
certainly didn't
he certainly didn't
thanks for that um
so our next meeting is on the 26th of
january 2022
um and at the same time and let's keep
our fingers crossed that the the
infection rate keeps going the right way
can i
real
send a big big thank you back to all our
public health staff
all the community engagement teams all
the ccg staff everyone involved in the
vaccination and booster programmes i
think you know what we've heard today is
that we're on the front foot in trafford
uh and uh
and we're just gonna have to keep
battling away
thank you very much indeed
thanks everybody
bye